[Music]
there was very little time for fear it
was more just like the hose was open and
was blasting in our face the entire time
but it's thrilling and this is you know
this is the challenge right to find the
stories of people who were sort of
understood as monsters and I want to see
the human in them there was this
internal debate when we were sending him
do we get him a tourist visa or do we
get him a journalist visa and so we
ultimately decided to send him on a
tourist visa and have him go undercover
we wouldn't be able to say he's
reporting on this particular issue so
we'd have to essentially be lying to the
Russian government about what Jeff was
doing there because you know he is out
in the field reporting with openly gay
individuals which is itself a crime in
Russia to be seen with such people to be
talking to them especially with the
reporters notebook in hand it's it's
this huge red flag and we knew that he
was putting himself at a certain degree
of risk the real turning point of this
story for me was in sort of making me
realize I was also interested in the
sort of the courage that people show in
everyday life and the courage was the
only option to survive you know the
journalists can sort of say well I'm
doing this for the story but after
you've been with these people with his
courage he sort of wanted you know I
became like one of those guys in the
bunker we're saying let's let's hide you
need a good enemy you don't want to
punch down channelling all the anger in
your life toward this right but not
using it to write a story that is like a
baseball bat or the story that does have
some remedy to transform that and that's
where you know that you are right on the
edge of how things are made and it's
worth knowing about that and if you can
describe that edge and maybe push it
back with a boo back then you make more
room for the human
you